what is going on everybody and welcome
to part 13 of our intermediate Python
programming tutorial series in this
tutorial what we're going to be doing is
jumping into object-oriented programming
so objects are any programming is a
concept that's a little hard to define
in very few words but I think it's a lot
easier to understand when you just do it
but the purpose of object-oriented
programming is to create objects and
these objects have attributes and then
they also have methods so the attributes
are like characteristics and the methods
are basically actions or ways for us
that we can actually interact with these
objects now for this tutorial I'm going
to be making use of Pi game which is a
pretty simple game library for Python it
works really well at least on Windows
and Linux on Macintosh it's a little
more difficult but you can go to PI game
dot org slash wiki slash Macintosh and
they have like updated instructions at
least it looks here like media will work
on the latest Python 3 as far as I know
it definitely works on 3.1 so you might
have to get a different version of
Python that might be kind of annoying
but I do think that PI game or some
other way of actually visually seeing
what you're working with is an
exceptional way to learn either just
programming in general or some sort of
programming concept especially
object-oriented programming where we're
creating this thing that has like
characteristics and does things and is
interacted with and objects can interact
with each other and all this kind of
stuff I think it makes a lot of sense to
use something like PI games so we can
actually visualize what's happening as
well so that's what we're going to do on
Windows and Linux you should just be
able to do pip install PI game and
you're good to go
so hopefully you can figure that out if
you have questions feel free to ask in
the in the comments and otherwise
let's get started so first of all the
thing that creates an object is a class
so we're going to define we'll just
start by defining a class and we're
going to call this class blob and what
we're going to do at least to start is
we're going to be creating a sort of
blob world that consists of an
environment that these blobs are living
within and the blobs will interact with
each other but also just the general
environment that can do things in the
environment but first we need to define
what this blob object actually is what
are its attributes and what are things
that this blob can actually do so just
class blob : and you're good to go
and right away we're going to define the
first our first method and what we're
going to do is we're going to define the
dunder itter or not send Ritter ah
dunder init method donor hitter will
come eventually
but dunder init is the person we're
going to do and we're going to pass self
and then we're going to pass color so
what these arguments do is self is just
this this instance it's this object
instance that we're going to be able to
share throughout the entire object here
so throughout the entire class the
things that we define is like self dot
something like to start we're going to
have maybe self dot color since we're
passing color here that's going to have
some sort of value we're going to set
that to be whatever color is so now this
object this is an attribute of this
object right and we can reference it in
the definition of the class anywhere and
in another method it doesn't have to be
in the init method so we can reference
this elsewhere using self dot but then
outside of this when we actually do
create the object and save it to a
variable name we do that variable named
color and that is how we can access the
color attribute you'll see that more as
when we get there but self is just you
can pick any name for self but self is
just the standard
kind of protocol that people use since
we're trying to do as proper as possible
code code that scales code that can be
read by other people we're going to call
that self and we're not going to deviate
from that I'm not sure I've ever seen
anyone deviate from that but you could
if you wanted to be a real jerk so
anyway there we have that the other
things that we're going to add to this
blob basically the the init method what
this is going to do is when the when the
object is created
whatever the init method is is just
going to run okay so when when the blob
is born these are things that are going
to be set about the blob
so we're saying when this blob is born
it's assigned a color because we've got
color as a as an argument here we're
also going to assign it a location
because it's going to be born and it's
going to appear in this environment
somewhere so we're going to say self dot
X and we're going to say this we have an
imported random but we'll do that in
here in a second random dot R and range
and we'll say it's zero to the width and
we also don't have width yet we're going
to we'll bring that one in as well but I
just wanted to keep this just the class
for now but the width will be the the
width of the the environment basically
so in pygame you'll bring up a window
we'll probably do like 800 by 600
so width will be like 800 pixels so this
could be anywhere between 0 and 800 then
we're going to do set loops then we'll
do self dot y equals random dot R and
range and this will be 0 to the height
now we're going to do a self dot size so
how big is the blob going to be
basically these are just all things that
we have to know about the blob to show
the blob on the screen right we need to
know at least these things that's why
they're going to be in the
initialization method here so self that
size we're going to random dot R and
range and this will be 4 to 8 it's a
little arbitrary seeming at the moment
but but pygame does sizes this way and
it isn't maybe it's pixels it's not
pixels I don't think it's not 4 to 8 so
I'm not really sure but obviously the
bigger you go we can kind of tweak that
and you'll see what
I mean it it's the same thing that's
like maybe I don't know I'm not really
sure what the what the metric is here
but anyway I don't think it's pixels uh
and then that's I think that's it that's
all we need nd dunder init method now
now we're going to say another method
and there are other basically the init
method again this is one of these
special methods of Python they're also
lovingly referred to as magic methods
and there are a lot of magic methods we
will talk about a few others I
accidently Freudian slip the dunder
itter method which we can use with
generators for example and a lot of
other cool things which I'm not really
sure blob will have added under it err
method but maybe who knows but anyways
there are a lot of magic methods but you
don't have to have them and similarly
you don't have to have an init method
you're well you have one you just don't
have to define one so you didn't have to
do this but in many cases you're going
to need you're going to want to set some
initial attributes so so we have one but
we can also define other methods and
methods pretty much look and act just
like functions okay
they just need self to be passed so this
next method we're going to call move
move and just for the record naming
conventions and such methods have the
same naming convention as functions
classes have Studley cased names so this
might be blob class or or something like
that but we're just going to keep it
blob one word so now the move method we
don't we're not going to pass anything
besides self here and we're just going
to say self dot move x4 now is going to
be equal to random dot R and range will
do negative one to two then we're going
to say self dot move Y will be equal to
random dot R and range negative one to
two again so this will be basically
anything from negative one it can be any
possibility negative one zero or one so
in these movements these movements will
be in pixel
so at each frame it can either move it
can move one pixel in any direction up
to one anyways sometimes it might not
then we're going to say we're going to
update self dot X so this is how we're
kind of sharing we're not redefining
necessarily what we are redefining but
basically this is going to modify the
self dot X attribute and we're gonna say
plus equals self dot move X and then
self dot y we're going to say plus
equals self don't move Y now the idea is
that this is going to interact in an
environment and for now we're going to
set some limitations on the blob class
and we're just going to say that we know
it's interacting with in this window of
width and height so we're going to go
ahead and just say basically if self dot
X is less than zero we're going to say
self dot x equals zero l if self dot X
is greater than the width we're going to
say self dot x equals so x equals the
width and then we're gonna do the same
thing basically with y so we're gonna
say if self lips we're going to say if
self dot y is less than zero self dot y
equals zero and then LF self dot y is
greater than the height we're going to
say self dot y equals height cool
so where do that alternatively one thing
you can do just because this takes up a
lot of space you can do this and put
those on one line I'll let you decide
which you think is better personally I
find this to be cleaner if you've got
really simple simple information I think
it's easier to read personally so if
you're not really having too much on
each one I don't see a problem with this
but if I was to guess I would say that's
not Pepe
but I'm going to keep it on one line I
preferred on one line
I think it's more beautiful so we have
ourselves are starting blob class and I
think what I'm going to do is stop it
here that's all we're going to add to
the blob class for now and in the next
tutorial we are going to use PI game
we're going to create the environment
and we're going to plop this blob into
the environment and see what we got so
if you have questions comments concerns
up to this point feel free to leave them
below otherwise I'll see you in the next
tutorial